Prime Minister Boris Johnson has been
admitted to hospital ten days after
testing positive for the corona virus
for more on this let's bring in Miriam
namazi she's joining us from London via
Skype what more are you hearing about
the Prime Minister's condition Miriam
right so we have learned this evening
that Prime Minister Boris Johnson as you
say has been admitted to hospital this
is after having symptoms of the corona
virus for the past 10 days which he
tested positive for it's worth
mentioning that it's not an emergency
admission currently we just know that he
is been admitted to hospital for tests
and that's pretty much the extent of it
a spokesperson from Downing Street has
released a statement saying that he was
admitted hospital on the advice of his
doctor and it's been described as a
precautionary step that has been taken
because of the persistent nature of his
symptoms but interesting that he still
remains very much in charge of the
business of government is and is still
in contact with ministers and officials
and that is something that Downing
Street has really emphasized of course
Boris Johnson has been working remotely
for the past 10 days he has been in
isolation working from the flat above
number 11 Downing Street and he has been
having phone calls and conducting
meetings remotely and conducting cabinet
meetings and he's also been on social
media delivering messages to the public
about the importance of social
distancing and really making the point
that he is still very much in the
driving seat and still very much in
charge of the fight against the corona
virus but of course there will be a
great deal of curiosity and speculation
as to why he has been admitted to
hospital now this is what we don't know
at the moment why he has been admitted
hospital is it that he his symptoms have
deteriorated is it perhaps a logistical
thing because he would be able to access
medical advice and be able to access
specialists that he wouldn't otherwise
be able to is it just that the symptoms
are persistent but right now he remains
very much in charge of the government
now it was on
March 27th that we learnt of Boris
Johnson and the health secretary Matt
Hancock testing positive for the corona
virus after experiencing mild symptoms
of course Matt Hancock is now back at
work he is one of the the key faces in
those daily government briefings we get
updates about where the country is with
the epidemic but Boris Johnson has
remained in isolation it was interesting
because when that news came through on
March 27th there was really a flurry of
questions about who these two had been
in contact with in Westminster whether
other government ministers and other
officials might have been infected and
concerned that perhaps government
officials had not been following their
own advice on social distancing and then
there were also questions about
contingency measures about backup plans
what happens if the Prime Minister is
incapacitated and we know that in that
scenario it would be the farm Minister
Dominick rabe who would take charge but
right now as far as we know it is the
prime minister who is still very much in
charge this evening he has been admitted
into hospital we don't know precisely
why but it is the persistent nature of
his coronavirus symptoms that has
prompted this all right to marry mhmm
Ozzy thank you very much